salut c'est monsieur heureux dans la
série l'été de segré aujourd'hui on va
parler de télescopes forcément
aujourd'hui le temps est pas terrible
quand même plutôt relativement
dégueulasse dégraisser nuageux donc
forcément c'est pas beau mais ce sera
bientôt la nuit des étoiles d'ailleurs
des étoiles filantes de partout il va y
avoir tous les passionnés d'astronomie
qui vont sortir le bout de leur nez donc
justement aujourd'hui si vous parlez de
l'astronomie
parce que j'ai rencontré il ya pas très
longtemps une start-up hyper intéressant
qui propose en produits hyper cool c'est
à dire que si vous êtes fan d'astronomie
blé pour trouver un télescope destiné en
particulier aux six universités pour
pouvoir regarder bien évidemment là haut
vers les étoiles produit qui n'est pas
encore disponible mais qui devrait
sortir d'ici la fin de l'année début
d'année prochaine donc en attendant ils
sortent et en attendant de pouvoir
regarder les étoiles avec lui quand même
vous invite à y découvrir parce que
c'est un produit made in france super
intéressant labellisé friday qui on y va
[Musique]
qui a un statut qui lui permet de
regarder dans les étoiles introduit
super innovant est ce que tu peux nous
présenter nous expliquer en quoi ça
consiste
alors réuni stellar notre compagnie crée
des télescopes des télescopes pour
lowe's en public
donc on a notre premier produit ici est
le heavy scop les nazis jeunes 16 go qui
permet de
d'observer des as même si on ne connaît
rien d'antinomique les secrets c'est
qu'on a misé à l'intérieur du télescope
toutes les technologies modernes
utilisent les astronomes amateurs d'un
professionnel et on appelle ça nous a
permis d' un instrument qui est petit
compact puissants que les gens peuvent
utiliser pour observer des galaxies des
nébuleuses planétaires des comètes et
des astéroïdes dans leur jardin
donc ça veut dire que ce télescope c'est
vraiment introduit à la portée de tous
s'est agacé vous ciblez qui avec ses
avec ce
avec ce produit plutôt le particulier
qui est vraiment j'irai 1-1 amateurs
d'astronomie qui veut découvrir les
astres ou alors davantage le
professionnel avec une solution
une professionnelle je ne sais pas du
tout ce qu'on peut faire avec mais
j'imagine qu'il ya des solutions c'est
qu'ils vraiment le coeur de cible ce
produit le cas de ce type ce sont ces
les passionnés d'astronomie c'est là
c'est la population qui a envie
d'apprendre à regarder les as donc sa
part de simples personnes qui avaient
dans une ville
qui a envie de voir des étoiles vous
serez étoiles à sa famille que jusqu'à
des écoles et des universités qui ont
vite
de présenter la sodomie de manière utile
et fun alors étudiant d'accord qu'on
touche vraiment le grand public les
universités
[Musique]
le produit est disponible
commercialisés ou pas ou est ce que
c'est un proto constants le produit
n'est pas encore disponible
on est on a fini
on est passé en phase de production et
on aura le télescope très certainement
disponible à la fin d'année 2018 et 2019
il coûtera entre 1600 et 2000 2006 en
2002 la roque et donc sans le marché
français vous cibler un marché
international j'imagine tout est ok
alors d'un point de vue technique
est ce que tu peux m'expliquer un petit
peu comment ça marche parce que c'est un
petit peu abstrait pour moi j'imagine
pour beaucoup de monde
comment est ce qu'on a réussi à avoir un
télescope avec un format aussi petit on
peut positionner n'importe où comment
est ce que vous avez fait d'un point de
vue purement technologique
on a intégré toutes les technologies
modernes qui existe actuellement
on à l'intérieur des télescopes
détecteur
secteur assez classique assez robuste et
très sensible on a un calculateur un
ordinateur à bord fait des calculs pour
pour nous et frontier d'une carte delà
de la sphère céleste avec 26 millions
des toiles et enfin on a un système
taillé système de projecteurs qui
projette l'image dans
dans un objectif que la personne puisse
me lisez regardez
aussi regarder directement sur un
territoire
d'accord on connecte avec le smartphone
on peut le kilo texan soir fabre le
pilote avec le smartphone c'est il se
connecte avec nos smartphones on sait
qu'on peut lui donner des poubelles
bouger de manière aléatoire direction du
ciel et on peut aussi
aussi près des pulsions d'objets
intéressant sachant la localisation
kwixo laurent cliquer sur la
l'objet conserver le télescope à ce
calibre est tout seul se déplacer tout
seul berger s'aligner ce
se mettre en position
observation on quand les installations
sont prêtes à prendre regardez dans le
l'image est
donc c'est vraiment génial merci
beaucoup on va suivre ça de très près
dites moi vous en commentaire ce que
vous en pensez
est ce que vous êtes amateurs
d'astronomie est ce que le télescope
comme celui ci pourrait vous intéresser
vous mettez tout ça je suis sûr c'est
très intéressant vous avez bien
évidemment à rester connectés à vous
abonner à l'essai des jolies choses
parce que c'est une solution de dingue
je vous dis à très bientôt
à bientôt et merci merci
[Musique]